ok on est pareil tu en trouves tu fais
tu as tout gâcher nyota qu'elle
introduit veut faire tutu montre aux
gens que je suis une merde
les amis souvenez-vous avec nous à la
fois on avait créé des monstruosités
on avait créé des chats très bizarre
mais aussi des sacs à main et des
chaussures et des chaussures oui c'était
nul à se poser la question alors petite
info audio et au lendemain de soirée
bon ça va bien se passer oui ça va très
bien dans la nuque
ça va mieux c'est bon il est remis sur
pattes la bonne nouvelle du jour c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya la même chose qui
est sorti mais avec des visages c'est à
dire que là on a dessiné des visages et
ça va générer à partir de 200 photos je
crois la base de données c'est un train
du genre c'est un mixer les photos pour
faire l'image qu'on a dessiné un exemple
ci contre a que tu l'un d'eux dessinée
que je viens de décider moi-même bien
sûr mais aussi nommer c'est bien du tout
et parce que les gens et là dernier de
pipe douala merci qui commence ok j'ai
un jeu pour départ et celui qui fait
tourner souhaite finir le plus longtemps
on va changer c'est gentil vas-y fais
nous rêver
je vais tenter un truc très un visage je
pense qu'on commence classique là dessus
tout ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
l'interface pour dessiner est absolument
ignobles way home à la glace c'est pas
précis voilà si ce n'est par exemple
ressemble au nez de maxence c'est parce
que le ce que c'est un portrait de max
en battant et afin plus trop bien la
news je savais j'aurais pu faire
commencer ce conflit baal couteau à la
main on travaille on devrait cette fois
neo c'était une manière de faire arrêter
de dessiner est ce que tu es prêt aux
mecs pourquoi je suis déçu parce que le
bras et stylos bas et trop bien les
bains etc ou le bail trop bien mais le
haut est moins bien moi je pense je peux
le dire un truc le prend mal je pense
juste que tu sais pas dessiner ça va un
moment il faut voir il faut les comptes
j'essaye non mais ouais il faut remettre
le stylo entre les mains de voilà bon
alors je vais dessiner comme quand
j'étais petit ok c'est moi c'est des
mecs franchement mec je consacre si l'on
sait que là je suis sûr et certain que
j'ai déjà vu des trucs comme ça dans des
expos d'art moderne schluss et mais pour
depuis c'est terrifiant par contre c'est
vraiment
c'est bon c'est bon allez à toi ok
peut-être un truc de dingue ça passe
mieux je sais pas
je sais que c'est ce genre de profil
c'est moi je trouve beaucoup plus dures
de dessiner des femmes c'est vrai ouais
parce que georges pas je vais est
officiellement sexiste non non non juste
pas certains jeux une femme c'est
élégant mais c'est sa maison
c'est pour ça c'est dur c'est homogène
vraiment c'est des courbes tout est dans
les courbes et les carrés est ce qu'on
est et rôles actuellement mais c'est une
forme actuelle a dû renoncer par des
mecs
j'espère tellement franchement tu mérite
tellement kit ok ok tentes mais il n'y a
pas assez de très rare je croyais très
rajoute des toits et sam les cheveux
fermé je vous rajoute des traits dans la
chute des cheveux cas là non en fait il
est alors je pense en fait flou à
mondeville faut dessiner mais j'ai je
peux tenter un truc si c'est encore un
jeu de mots à la con comme notre foi en
un an
c'est juste faire un smiley est là
qu'est ce que c'est que ça et vite
c'est quand même pas loin d'être le
meilleur qu'on ait fait donc je vais
essayer aussi un truc genre semaine est
un peu plus simple genre carte ou nantes
il va vraiment être tout petit effet et
faire visage hiver la forme de fraise
jamais une fraise n'a été si vilaine
attention aux mets ont les yeux ça va
mais les jeunes chevaux
j'aime par terre yann barthès viennent
si tu regarde cette vidéo c'était moche
c'est pas ton sourire non aux palois si
quand il dit bienvenue dans mon
quotidien
ok tu es prêt oui pourquoi j'ai fait une
phrase il ya les malédictions frey
malédiction j'aime les fruits juste une
question
oui c'est une fois moins nobles c'est
une chose oh pas mal pas mal pas mal pas
mal
par contre il est un coquin
comme lui il s'est fait tabasser et aux
portiques et aux vidéos tirées le
couteau du sac et ses salles à tabasser
non mais c'est vrai elle mec jalala jeu
si je peux me permettre je pense que
j'ai gagné accueille actuellement mais à
chaque fois mais parce qu'en fait je
pense c'est fait pour ce que des signes
très très mal débuté un vrai artiste
ça marche pas avec sa série toujours
allez vas-y à toi je pas confère qu'est
ce que je fais
franchement mon frère tu fais iron man
[Musique]
alors non c'est le ironman humain ne
laissait pas fait pour ça dans celle ci
les stylistes et je passais de moyenne
enfin je veux dire stéphanie c'est fait
je ferais pas un câlin quoi ça très bien
on est vraiment c'est que on a mis à le
masquer sous la peau d'un mec c'est très
fort et joyeux mais ce jeu passe
peut-être devant moi ok antoine daniel
ok bon on est d'accord tu n'as plus loin
daniel le matin là je sens que ça va
juste donner une boule de poils aux
jeunes agnel direct c'est pas parce
qu'il a un petit épi sur le côté moi je
trouve ça plutôt style attends j'ai
envie de wiimote spyder eu ben oui on
n'est pas là il a des cheveux au bout de
chaque assez incroyable de dire qu'on
dirait du tableau s'est fait conduire un
peu d assurer un test au pire on veut
censurer tout ça y est on avec mes
frères à bâle a beaucoup je suis désolé
et voilà c'est la fin de cette vidéo
personnelle au regard des listes et
palais mais si elle vous a plu merci
nude est venu n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à sa chaîne comme d'habitude
comme des gens qui passent dans mes
vidéos aller voir leurs chaînes sur fait
extrêmement plaisir à la bientôt les
amis portez vous bien
[Musique]
ça